news from the steelers titans game
postponed until monday or tuesday there
was a report from paul kucharski who
covers the titans yesterday that the cbs
crew has been told to plan on monday
andrew marshawn to the new york post
reported last night that the game will
be nationally televised by cbs and if
it's monday
it's five o'clock
eastern which sets up a de facto monday
night double header which is good
because i thought it was going to be you
know chris in the past when there'd be a
world series situation that would bump a
game to a monday night both would be
played at the same time but the game
that got bumped would be
just in the local markets
uh and so you wouldn't get to see both
games
maybe they'd put it on directv something
like that but no no they're setting up a
week one style monday night double
header that starts a hell of a lot
earlier so you don't have to stay up
till after one o'clock so there's a
small silver lining definitely this
covet 19 outbreak that that looks like
it's going to bump the game to monday or
tuesday yeah i mean that it's awesome it
really is what first thing is mike i
mean i hope it's monday i don't know how
you can realistically ask a team like if
they're going to play tuesday then they
need to move next week's tennessee
titans and pittsburgh's games too and
that the next monday too and reorganize
that that's not fair either to play
tuesday and then ask them hey come back
sunday and certainly not fair to the
pittsburgh steelers who have done
nothing wrong here uh mike i don't know
i don't know how you feel i'm still a
little bit of like i think they should
play sunday you know as long as
everything's safe i hope they're not
doing this just to give the titans an
extra day of preparation i i don't
because i don't think that's fair i
really don't again i just the way it is
i know this is it's not a fair year for
anybody and i get that but uh i guess it
just bothers me a little that way
regardless it's good that we're gonna
have a game monday but i don't know you
you feel the same way as i do or are you
okay with this monday move and all this
uh look it's two separate issues moving
to monday gives the titans a chance to
at least have maybe a practice saturday
a walk through sunday to get their act
together to get their game plan from
paper to practice yeah that's one thing
moving the game to tuesday night chris
and i want to
focus on this a little bit yeah what it
does is it puts the titans and the
steelers in position where they have to
turn around and play five days later
right which is fine if you're playing a
team that also has only five days to get
ready like on a thursday night you never
see a team play on a short week from a
sunday to thursday against a team that
also isn't in that same boat right you
don't have a team coming off of a bye
week for example playing on a thursday
night so it's equal hardship to get
ready in a compressed time frame what
would happen is the bills in the titans
play week five the bills have the full
week to get ready the titans have five
days in between games steelers and
browns play browns have the whole week
to get ready the steelers have five days
in between like you said steelers have
done nothing wrong here so on one hand
we have to accept an assortment of
competitive disadvantages this year if
and when there are outbreaks on the
other hand there's got to be a way to
manage it and i agree with you if they
would move
steelers titans to tuesday night
then there should be three monday night
games all right the following monday
bills titans steelers browns plus the
game that's scheduled which i believe is
chargers saints in that monday night
window and i don't know that they're
going to get that
exotic but here's the thing
this is the one year where you can
flex games from sunday to monday to
tuesday to saturday to whenever because
you don't have to worry for the most
part now in some of these cities you do
have to worry about the hardship on fans
because they're letting fans attend
but for the most part that's not a
factor
and you can you can you can move the
games on the chessboard however you want
to accommodate fairness or you just
accept the fact that pro football life
in a pandemic ain't fair
and you just have to deal with whatever
you have to deal with chris well yeah i
guess that that is the question right
but where is that line drawn
you know to me it's like
i would like the nfl to stay along the
guidelines and keep everybody to have
the incentive of going no if you were on
your p's and q's and act appropriately
when you're away from football
you know this is the incentive and right
now we're we're we're letting one team
kind of off the hook is what i'm saying
that's right that's i guess that's where
i don't like it as long as we you know
like okay the testing we've gone through
everybody's good all of that i
understand if there were still players
that were coming up positive and then we
have to move the day but we haven't
heard anything here
you know we're about 48 hours past i
think we've had you know we've had tests
done and all of that
i just don't like what what
i'm not i'm not giving you a technical
i'm so i'm calling a quick time out an
incubation period that we need to be
concerned about right because you don't
show up positive within 24 to 48 hours
it can be a three or four day thing yeah
so there's still a chance that you know
they send the test samples out for a
24-hour turnaround so
wednesday testing of the titans players
and personnel
could result
in positives today because the samples
collected wednesday yeah may show that
guys are positive based upon exposure
that happened on sunday see that that
we're not out of the woods yet yeah okay
that's right this month this monday
tuesday possibility isn't aimed
i believe it by maybe it is buying time
to just see where the dust settles on
all of this because there is a chance
there's going to be more positives and
we we don't know for sure
when the titans can reopen their
facility until everyone who potentially
has been exposed has had a chance
to shed virus that's the key yeah but i
think that's one of the reasons why they
they shut the doors until saturday we
want to have a full opportunity for
anyone who's ever going to be positive
to be positive then we know who stays
out and who stays in now depending upon
how many are positive the titans could
be short-handed which is a different
hardship yeah than than the the titans
having to shut their facility all week
and not being able to practice chris
before we address though this question
of whether or not it's fair or unfair to
give a dispensation to the titans let's
hear from the two head coaches involved
yeah they addressed it on wednesday mike
frable of the titans and mike tomlin the
steelers here they are
i know there's going to be a lot of
questions
about the game and about who's to blame
and where it started
um
nobody's to blame
you know
we're in a pandemic
unfortunately things happen john and i
feel comfortable that since
receiving the protocols in august we
followed those
by the letter
and that we were
that's an opportunity to do that
probably easier than normal
circumstances
you know interesting point by tomlin
that that having everything really
stripped down and focused and and
limited movement limited exposure he's
got the full attention of his players at
all times whatever message he wants to
send it's getting through they went
forward with their basic installation
day the major wednesday practice when
you get ready for your opponent but back
to vrabel he says no one's to blame here
well
i mean some would say china's to blame
from the get-go
not me i'm just saying something there's
blame somewhere yeah it's not just hey
it happens somewhere there's blame when
the
virus makes its way into your facility
either there's blame on the quality of
the protocols put in place to keep the
virus out right or just blame the
individuals involved who brought the
virus in some way somehow someone's to
blame for something that the nfl has
taken such great pains to keep out of
the 32 facilities someone did something
they shouldn't have done somewhere
somehow to allow this virus to get in
whether
someone a coach or a player went
somewhere they shouldn't have gone or a
family member went somewhere they
shouldn't have gone weren't
appropriately careful in the use of
personal protective equipment whatever
the case may be but somebody at some
point allowed themselves into a position
where they caught the virus and one
thing led to another and they have an
outbreak in tennessee so someone is to
blame here there was a failure somewhere
of what the nfl has set up so it was
poorly designed or poorly executed but
someone's to blame well yeah obviously
there's no doubt about it and that's
where you know you you get into the
blame game like let's listen i don't i i
believe mike vrabel and and uh the gm
you know
they're they're they're like caring
good people want to do it the right way
i don't really doubt that any teams
aren't doing anything right in the
protocols and the things that are put in
place it's not about that it's about
what your guys what we've talked about
from the beginning
who what guys can you trust that are
doing the right things off the field and
you know
how would you feel about this
if you know you're the pittsburgh
steelers and all sudden the video comes
out next week or whatever and you see
that there was like some titans players
at some gathering like the raiders and
that's what maybe started this or
whatever it is like you know that that
that to me is again where like you said
a little while ago
this is a year of not
fair no it's not fair you're right but
the greatest incentive still is to stay
healthy stay out of harm's way do the
right things off the field so we can
have football because it's so much
bigger than just it's it's us it's a lot
of people that are involved in this as
far as we need football to happen
because it you know is pays us and does
all these type of things to support our
lives and everybody else that's involved
in this so this is a big thing but i
just get back to it and go
you know again yeah not fair
but
why are we going to make it not fair for
the teams that are doing it the right
way sorry i you know and again it's not
like i want to blame anybody i
understand what mike vrabel is saying
it's a sensitive time i'm not like
looking here going like oh you got
idiots on your team yeah maybe you just
got unlucky but sorry you got unlucky
and you don't make it unfair for
everybody else just because one team was
wrong or did wrong or there is some
blame to
pass and then make it unfair for other
teams because that team has a mistake or
a hiccup that's just my feeling on that
and let's remember the titans first
round draft pick got cited for trespass
tennessee state university party he
shouldn't have been at that would have
exposed him potentially right over 19.
and then when he was on the covet 19
reserve list he got a dui which means he
was out about doing things
when he was you know supposed to be
in some degree of quarantine so you know
there are guys out there as we're going
to discuss in a minute or two that are
doing stupid things even if they would
look you straight in the eye and say
sorry what i did
wasn't really all that stupid it just
was
a little stupid but we'll get to that in
a second stupid i'm just having fun with
chris not the audience i'm looking into
the camera chris not the audience when i
say stupid
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports